احمد سعد يواجه ازمه في تونس رضوى
الشربيني في مازق مراسله مصريه تفقد النطق
وفي مصر المنافسه محتدمه على ايرادات موسم
سينما عيد الاضحى اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
بعد الحفل الذي احياهم مؤخرا بمدينه بنزرت
في تونس واجه المطرب المصري احمد سعد ازمه
مع بعض وسائل الاعلام التونسيه بسبب سجال
بينه وبين منظمه الحفل التي صعدت الموقف
ما بتعرفيش تعملي حفلات ولا بتعرفي تديني
حفلات احمد لم يخطط لاجراء لقاءات صحفيه
بعد الحفل وزعم ان تعاقده لم ينص على ذلك
وعاد الاجراء اللقاءات احتراما للصحافه
التونسيه لكن منظمه الحفل دعت عكس ذلك
وحينما حاول اسكاتها خرج الموقف عن
السيطره بحسب مقاطع فيديو تداولتها وسائل
اعلام تونسيه زعمت انه اساء لها وللمراه
التونسيه وعلق احمد سعد على ما جرى في
منشور له على انستجرام قال فيه وجدنا
منظمه الحفل تطيح بمبادئ احترام الفنان
واحترام القانون واطاحت ببنود العقد
المبرم بيننا وحاولت تشويهنا امام الاعلام
التونسي الحبيب واضاف خرجت للاعلاميين
لتوضيح الموقف احتراما للاعلام والجمهور
التونسي وما كان منها الى مقاطعتنا بشكل
غير لائق محاوله تشويه صوره الفنان المصري
امام الاعلام التونسي
[موسيقى]
ازمه اخرى ذات بعد اعلامي على مواقع
التواصل في مصر حينما اعلنت شبكه قنوات سي
بي سي لحاله المذيعه رضوى الشربيني
للتحقيق بسبب تدوينه نشرتها عبر صفحتها
الشخصيه على فيسبوك اعتبرت الشبكه انها
تسببت في اساءه باسم المؤسسه وتشير الصور
المتداوله للتدوين المحذوفه ان رضوى قالت
فيها مش فاهمه للبنات ما بتحبش تاكل لحم
الخروف بس بتحبي ترتبط بيه ولم يصدر حتى
تاريخه اي تعليق من الشربيني عن موضوع
حالتها للتحقيق
كما صدمت المراسله التلفزيونيه المصريه
اميمه بدري باعلانها فقدانها النطق بعد
تعرضها لحزن شديد المراسل المصريه طلبت من
متابعيها الدعاء لها وقالت انها اجرت اشعه
مقطعيه للمخ اظهرت عدم اصابتها بسكته
دماغيه لكن الطبيب المشرف على حالاتها وصف
لها بعض الادويه وطلب منها الراحه لمده
ثلاثه ايام قبل مراجعه طبيب اعصاب ما لم
تستعد القدره على الكلام وفي فيديو مؤثر
نشرته عبر صفحتها على فيسبوك ظهرت اميمه
بدري وهي تحاول النطق بصعوبه لتطمئن
متابعيها بعد ان استعادت القدره تدريجيا
على تحريك شفاهها واصدار اصوات يصعب
تفسيرها طالبه منهم الدعاء
[موسيقى]
بابا مش محتاج حاجه من الصيدليه بقى محتاج
تعمل له صابع جاريه والله فرحان لك اكنك
ابنك واخيرا وبعيدا عن الازمات لا زالت
المنافسه محتدمه في مصر على ايرادات موسم
سينما عيد الاضحى مع توتر تقارير اعلاميه
مصريه تفيد بتصدر فيلم بيت الروبي من
بطوله كريم عبد العزيز وكريم محمود عبد
العزيز الذي اطلق قبيل العيد قائمه
الايرادات يليه في الامتاج لتامر حسني
المصنف كاول فيلم بطل خارق عربي مع
الاعلان عن جزء ثاني منه وحل فيلم البعبع
الامير كراره في المركز الثالث من حيث حجم
الايرادات ويليه فيلم مستر اكس لاحمد فهمي
وهنا الزاهد في المركز الرابع